you're going into a 2-1 lead prior to
the last game how do you feel right now
oh obviously uh pretty good
considering i lost such a bad game in
the first one
a bit annoyed with the last game at some
point i
miscalculated and uh
from a position that's fairly equal but
very playable it becomes just an equal
ending but
yeah fortunately for
me he was a bit short at times i tried
to you know keep the game going a little
bit and he
uh and he started to make mistakes when
it comes to your second game was that
would you consider that a very well
played game by yourself
no
i i mean i did okay but he played pretty
badly i heard some parallels in someone
mentioning a previous game you had
against brunel a while back that was
quite similar did you think about that
at all yeah um
about 17 years ago um
no but this kind of technique
is well known from a bunch of carpool
games as well
he made a i mean he made a couple
mistakes early on but the crucial
mistake he made was
not exchanging bishops um
might seem paradoxical to um
to want to exchange the bishops when
there are bishops of opposite color
which should be in
general bead rush
but with my extra pawn and his targets
there were just no chances good luck in
the last game